foreign
we're here at Paul Ricard the F1 track
in the south of France we've got 11 of
our model S plans they're coming here
with the new track pack we're putting
them through their Paces out on the
circuit today
moles plaid is a beast on the track
because we intentionally designed it
that way with 10 20 horsepower coming
out of the powertrain incredible
acceleration with trackpac and its
upgraded brakes wheels and tires all the
performance limits are lifted and
balanced with the model S track package
we completely transformed the car with a
brand new track focused Tire paired with
a forged aluminum 20-inch wheel in
addition to our carbon ceramic brake
package most high performance brakes use
chopped fibers ours use continuous
fibers in the 3D Matrix the other
Innovation here is the ceramic friction
layer covering the entire surface and
creating this mirror finish the friction
consistency means you get predictable
braking performance whether you're
driving to the grocery store or on a
race track the Model S track back plan
really represents the vision at Tesla of
achieving a vehicle behavior and
response that is always very very true
to the driver inputs what this means is
that even the most demanding driver the
most sensitive will take this car to
limit and it will still have the highest
confidence in it
foreign